son jeune et provocante disponible jour
et nuit mais qui sont-elles
et quel agent tél certaines n'auraient
que 13 14 ou 15 à la clientèle qu'on
veut rejoindre c'est des gens qui
recherchent des fictions mineurs
bienvenue dans l'absurde réalité de ce
que les policiers appellent l' esclavage
des temps modernes
les petites annonces sur internet sont
devenus le véhicule de choix pour les
proxénètes qui exploite des adolescentes
et pour les clients qui lyrique la drs à
montréal et des femmes qui offrent des
services ici à montréal
et oui à des codes prostitution juvénile
qui se retrouvent ici à m'en informer
les yeux et de tous les sites d'annoncés
classées celui ci est devenu le chef de
file pour le commerce du sexe en
amérique du nord
montréal laval longueuil toronto
winnipeg vancouver partout ce sont sur
ces mêmes pages que les enquêteurs
cherchent de plus en plus et tous les
jours pour retrouver des adolescentes
portées disparues aux quatre coins du
pays y compris celles qui sont en fugue
à laval et à montréal même qu'à toronto
les 359 dossiers dans quête de traite de
personnes
ouvert depuis 2013 toutes les victimes
étaient annoncés ou vendus sur bach
p.com sans exception et ce même si la
compagnie offre des garanties à même son
site c'est surtout pour sauver les
apparences
nous continuons de notre côté de
recevoir des signalements évidemment
quand vous regardez le nombre le nombre
d'annoncés qui peuvent être publiées sur
ces sites là ça se compte par dizaines
de milliers quotidiennement selon
l'ampleur du site
lézat les auteurs de ces sites les
responsables de ces sites là ne peuvent
pas systématiquement tout vérifier alors
pourquoi les tolérer aux états unis ça
fait deux ans que la compagnie subit des
pressions pour fermer sa section adulte
qui lui rapporte des millions $ par mois
à washington le pdg carlos ferrero a
même été convoqué par un comité du sénat
il ne s'est jamais présenté deux
fugueuses américaine qui soutient
n'avoir été marchander à 15 ans aux
mêmes et tenter une poursuite accuse
l'entreprise d'avoir perfectionner un
modèle d'affaires lucratif complice de
l'exploitation sexuelle de
leur public à l'impression en regardant
les photos de ces de ses fillettes qui
sourit qui sont en costume de bain en
kiosque en fait ce sont des actes
volontaires
thain a bien émis assistent des
adolescentes dans cette poursuite
ce que nous savons c'est que très
souvent sinon toujours il y a le
proxénète de trafiquants qui est là
derrière avec le revolver à la tête
les géants comme visa mastercard et
american express ont déjà brisé les
liens avec la section adultes du site et
la pression continue mais où est la
mobilisation au canada la loi dit très
clairement que la publicité de la
prostitution des services sexuels est
interdite au canada et il a absolument
rien qui ait fait alors on se parle donc
moi je me questionne le procureur
général du québec le ministre la justice
qu'est-ce qu'il attend pour agir dans ce
dossier là pas seulement au niveau de la
publicité mais aussi au niveau 2 les
clients poutine encore savoir qui sont
ses clients c'est proxénète
de toute évidence les forces de l'ordre
ne sont pas encore à s'équiper pour les
déjouer
tamara ce n'est pas nouveau c'est sur
internet mais c'est un phénomène quand
même qui s'étend à un rite qui est
affolant oui parce que c'est facile
parce que c'est très payant et parce que
c'est beaucoup moins risqué c'est ce que
disent les proxénètes quand ils sont
interrogés que de vendre de la drogue
dans la rue et la preuve c'est grâce à
des sites comme celui ci mais en
ad'autres buy.com où les proxénètes
peuvent vendre leur marchandise
d'utiliser ce terme c'est le langage qui
est utilisé dans ce domaine là sans être
retracés c'est pas pour rien qu'une
compagnie comme craigslist
une autre annonce compagnie d'annoncés
classées a décidé de retirer sa section
adulte sous la pression populaire il ya
quelques années parce qu'elle savait
très bien ce qui se vendait dans cette
section là mais il ya des sites qui
prennent la relève
de plus en plus populaire au canada
anglais mais de plus en plus au québec
vous l'avez vu toutes les adresses à
montréal et dans sa banlieue
pourtant comme le disait madame hourani
existe des lois au canada
un an pour sévir contre ce genre de
publicité oui c'est compliqué oui c'est
se battre contre goliath vous avez vu on
sait ce qu'on fait aux états unis il ya
des dispositions dans la loi ce qui fait
dire à beaucoup d'observateurs qu'on
entend depuis du semaine depuis qu'il ya
toutes ces fugues à laval qui assoient
de problème soit un manque de volonté
politique ou un déni parce que c'est
tellement gros ça se passe ici ça se
passe chez nous et on ne veut pas y
croire ou un mélange des deux qui fait
qu'on en est là où on en est merci
beaucoup tamara je vous en prie